[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings at 7 30. a
cbs news investigation into allegations
of fraud waste and abuse at the
department of alcohol tobacco firearms
and explosives is now prompting
congressional action hundreds of
millions of taxpayer dollars may be
involved here senior investigative
correspondent catherine harris broke the
story and she's live for us now at the
agency's headquarters catherine good
morning to you
good morning the top republican on the
senate committee with oversight says
he's got deep concerns that the atf may
have broken the rules when it gave bonus
pay to employees at taxpayers expense
after an atf whistleblower who asked to
be disguised and not to use his last
name when on the record with cbs news
how big is the bump up in pay 25
as soon as joe an army veteran got to
the atf's human resources department in
2016 he said he noticed personnel
problems they would bring every
agent that wanted to be promoted to the
headquarters that would spend time there
doing a whole lot of jobs desk jobs desk
jobs a variety of jobs to which they
weren't even minimally qualified and joe
told us there was another issue even
though some atf personnel were doing
administrative jobs joe told us they
were paid a bonus known as law
enforcement availability pay or leap for
short people were receiving it in
positions where they weren't authorized
government regulations stipulate the
extra pay is reserved for criminal
investigators who are on call and
expected to work on scheduled additional
hours how much money are we talking
about for an individual employee if you
were making a hundred thousand dollars
and you got leave you would get 125 000.
joe doesn't know how long it's been
going on or how much money has been
wasted but colleagues told them that was
the atf way what do you mean the atf way
well this is what they've done for 30
plus years
to what i was told after telling a
senior atf official in 2018 what he'd
found joe got this email from his
supervisor saying his bosses were upset
joe's performance reviews went from
fully successful before going to
management to minimally successful after
what did you
take away is the message don't look over
there just because you see someone
stealing money at the atm you don't have
to say anything in june last year a
federal lawyer told joe the office of
special counsel found a substantial
likelihood of wrongdoing since the
government's hr office suspended the
atf's authority to create certain jobs
for no less than six months this seems
to be a waste of taxpayers money senator
chuck grassley is the top republican on
the senate committee with direct
oversight of the atf while four agencies
are investigating joe's case over a
three-year period none of it reached
grassley's office should someone have
told your committee you're absolutely
right it boils down to the fact that
agencies don't like to be
embarrassed by these revelations that
come from whistleblowers because of the
cbs report grassley's investigators sent
these letters to the atf the justice
department and the federal government's
hr agency demanding records and answers
will you ask your investigators to find
out if it's happening at other agencies
well my suspicion is it probably is
we're going to find out how widespread
it is four months ago joe lost his job
his supervisor said he was inconsistent
following instructions and argumentative
among other issues are you a difficult
employee if what you're asking me to do
is illegal unethical immoral yes i'm
going to be difficult because i'm not
going to do it
an email from the office of special
counsel reviewed by cbs news says a
final report into joe's claims is
delayed citing broad implications for
the atf four government agencies
declined to answer our questions and now
they'll have to respond to the senator
later this month nate
catherine thank you